una reina que no emitía opiniones
políticas pero que fue una presencia
inmutable en las decisiones de Reino
Unido la relación entre el número 10 de
Downey Street y el Palacio de buckingham
durante el reinado de Isabel II estuvo
lleno de altibajos
el primer Primer Ministro que se
arrodilló ante la reina fue el
conservador Winston el político que
lideró a Reino Unido durante la Segunda
Guerra Mundial Tuvo una relación muy
cercana con la monarca Churchill ejerció
de mentor de una joven Isabel En un
momento en el que el Imperio británico
empezaba a hacer aguas y la Guerra Fría
se instalaba en el mundo
vinieron los conservadores Anthony Eden
conocido por su controvertido manejo de
la crisis de suez en 1956 Harold
macmillan quien aceleró el proceso de
descolonización y Álex Douglas home que
duró menos de un año en el cargo con el
laborista Harold Wilson la reina Tuvo
una buena sintonía el premiere condujo
al país en los convulsos años 60 una
época marcada por las continuas huelgas
los expertos se resaltan su labor al
lado de Isabel ya que supo explicar a la
soberana Cómo funcionan el partido
laborista y los sindicatos un mundo
hasta ahora desconocido para ella tras
Wilson siguieron Edward hit con quien
Reino Unido ingresó en la comunidad
económica Europea y el laborista James
Garden
finalizando la década de los 70 llegaría
a Down Street margaret thatcher La Dama
De Hierro por primera vez en la historia
una mujer de la misma edad de la reina
gobernaría el país con Tacher tuvo
diferencias profundas más que con
cualquier otro premiar durante mucho
tiempo las audiencias con la reina
fueron bastante tensas pese a los
encuentros con La Dama De Hierro Isabel
nunca estuvo de acuerdo con la manera en
la que los conservadores sacaron a
Tacher del cargo la década de los
noventas comenzó con John Major con
Quien comenzó el proceso de paz de
Irlanda del Norte siguió Tony Blair
recordado por apoyar a Estados Unidos en
la invasión de Afganistán e iraq en 2007
llegaría Gordon Brown y en 2010 David
Cameron recordado por llamar al
referendo en el que el Reino Unido
optaría por abandonar la Unión Europea
de 2019 a 2022 dos primeros ministros
fugaces pasaron por down Street the
ambos encargados de llevar a cabo el
brexit este último con éxito dos días
antes de su muerte esta sería su última
foto dándole la bienvenida a la actual
Premier
70 años de reinado Isabel vio pasar a 15
primeros ministros